l'homosexualité est elle une mallette
voilà une question qui peut choquer
aujourd'hui
pourtant elle était au coeur des débats
dans les années 70 et 80
car dans ces années-là l'homosexualité
et est catégorisé comme une maladie
mentale en france dans les émissions
médicales des psychiatres expliquait
alors leurs méthodes pour prendre en
charge ce symptôme comme il disait tout
à l'heure on l'a on a parlé de cette
réunion des problèmes homosexuels qui
pouvait y avoir et question que je
pouvais à se poser à ce moment là c'est
jusqu'où doit-on aller dans la tolérance
le santo certains psychanalystes était
persuadé de connaître les causes de
cette fameuse maladie
tout viendrait de la mer il faut revenir
aux sources et au niveau de l' influence
de la mer et aussi de l'affluence du pet
il faut faire remonter et cause
principale de l'homosexualité est bien
fluence de la mer c'est la mère
dominatrice c'est la mère qui couve son
fils et la mère y détient tout
d'autorité c'est la mère qui écrase de
paix baigné dans ce contexte où
homosexualité égale maladie et même
perversion certains homosexuels
cherchait alors à se faire soigner par
de longues psychanalyse tout ce que j'ai
fait tout ce que j'ai tenté pour le
faire sont là en fait rien donné c'est
bien ce que voulait absolument me
démontrer que j'étais un même normal que
c'était bon un accident fatigue etc
au même moment dans le milieu homo
certaines voix s'élever je sais pas
pourquoi les gens comprennent pas ça
ces photos c'est pas une maladie on a
toujours dit que c'était une maladie
mais moi depuis l'âge de 5 ans j'ai eu
envie de m'habiller en femme subit en
femme j'ai grandi j'ai gt gt une gamine
à l'école si tu veux je t'ai pas un
garçon est alors cessé un état normal
pour moi je me rends compte qu'ils
habitent la rue qs prennent ça comme un
état anormal comme une maladie comme une
tarte
il faudrait attendre 1982 pour que les
lois discriminantes envers les
homosexuels soit abolie et 1983 pour que
l'état ne considère plus l'homosexualité
comme une maladie mentale
de quoi réjouir les associations comme
le comité d'urgence anti répression
homosexuels par exemple en effet dans
ces qualifications
l'oms considère la sexualité celle de
l'homme ceux de la forme comme une
maladie mentale essor en france ça a
disparu
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
c'est sera seulement en 1990 de
considérer l'homosexualité comme une
maladie mentale
[Musique]